it is cause for excitement in my
household because
the uh episode number 12 of season
number two of ted lasso is available
tonight the depressing aspect of it
however is that it is the season finale
of ted lasso season number two and thus
we will have to wait for more for quite
some time and the man who plays jamie
tart of afc richmond fame once again
phil dunster
here on the rich eisen show how are you
phil
ahoy i'm very well thanks mate yes yeah
devastated that uh we don't get to tune
in again for another
few months but uh but yeah i'm very well
thanks man thanks for having me on well
it is an incredible show um that you're
a part of phil this is a phenomenon for
a reason because not only is it um
um funny but it's also so heartwarming
and actually
enhances
enjoyment as this episode goes along
even when it is
kind of
um difficult and dramatic in its way how
do you find this show being a part of it
phil dunster what do you like about it
well i i think that i mean those are all
very nice things to say thank you and
also it feels it's funny because when
you're filming it you know it's a cliche
isn't it when you're
uh you're just happy to be a part of
something like that and uh and it's nice
to hear all those things but when we
film it it's like it just feels like a
really nice show where there are lots of
funny people who are making each other
laugh
um you know it doesn't feel like
we're doing god's work in the sense you
know i think that
that seems to hit a bit of a zeitgeist
thing and that's for other people to say
and it's very nice to hear it but um
uh
it it it does feel like there's you know
it feels like there's
something special when you watch it uh
and it's it's funny to think that you
know there's lots of there's lots of
superhero movies and it seems like ted
alaska's super powers kindness and
empathy and uh
and sort of um
you know uh compassion so yeah it it it
does feel like the world needs that and
it's very it feels great to be a part of
the show that
that is giving that to people honestly i
i get there i sit around my wife and i
we watch it and we just when the credits
roll we're just blown away and i'm
serious like normally that's associated
with a drama like i've had feelings like
that and this is the truth watching
shows like game of thrones sopranos uh
the wire
those types of shows where my wife and i
look at each other when the credits roll
and we want to know who wrote it who
directed it and we want to know
literally everything about it it is that
special that's the way i feel about it
phil well yeah i think that it does feel
like that
that and that the curiosity that
inspires you hopefully is a thing that
we tried to tap it into in the show i
think i think it just has some really
simple
uh lessons in it and it you know at its
most it feels like it's got some really
lovely simple lessons in there that you
you know the idea of curiosity not
judgment i think it's such a simple but
kind of i don't know when i heard it i
was like god that feels quite profound
um and uh and so you go away and it
feels like you've sort of been been
taught something but you know it but
it's at its at it's sort of least it's
uh a show that
that is like it's a funny show and you
know you go there
for
you know you know nate making funny
weird jokes and and higgins making his
weird jokes and then you stay for sam
obasanja breaking your heart and uh and
you know you fall in love with with uh
with keely
um
and like her earnestness and and so yeah
it feels like there's something for
everyone no i guess hopefully yeah it is
phil dunster who plays jamie tart here
on the rich eisen show let's dish a
little bit sir who are you playing who
from the real world of football are you
channeling do you think
well there's an amalgam okay probably
for my my lawyer would tell me that i
have to say as an amalgam
jamie's based on um
people like jack relish from the
sartorial sort of style
um
cristiano ronaldo who would love to
believe that he's got a bit of his swag
a bit of his uh footballing style
bernardo silva there's a bit of neymar
in there um and uh you know but but
there's you know any any sort of elite
footballer has to have a sort of undying
self belief uh and you know there's
plenty of footballers out there that uh
that can you can take inspiration from
for that yeah you do have the the hair
the eyebrows down of elite footballer
you've got that one
nailed phil
you've got that one nailed down well i
grew that bit myself but uh it was
styled by lovely mickey austin um but
yeah thank you very much you're welcome
now is it true you have also nailed down
the 40
what uh 40 what would 40 meter free kick
what are you yeah in season
yeah in season two episode six jamie
tark spoiler alert has a free kick
is this true phil dunster you're the one
who literally in real life no cgi tucked
that under the
the crossbar perfectly in the corner
yeah
you might be able to see me squeezing my
eyes and praying whilst i do it
it was um it was one of those moments
where i was like god that was a good
time to have a fluke but no i i played a
lot of rugs i know the story of it is
basically that i read it in the script
and in my mind for anyone who is sort of
familiar with
um the cristiano ronaldo free kick
cannon uh there is there's a a famous
free kick that he has about 45 yards out
in the semi-final the champions league
um which is you know one of the biggest
domestic football competitions
and uh so in that you want to you know
you you don't want to take too many
chances but cristiano ronaldo took upon
himself to go no no i'll probably score
this if i take it and you know hit it as
hard as i can
um and so i think that i was like yeah
i'm going to take i want to channel that
if i can but obviously that to actually
do that you need to be cristiano ronaldo
and hence the praying and the uh
you know uh the the shutting of the eyes
but no i i used a lot of rugby so i
think you could maybe see there's quite
like a website just getting them all but
yeah but that has to rank up no matter
what you do the rest of your career
certainly amongst uh your your cast
mates and the crew and whatever that's
got to rank up there as
that's a walk-off as we might say an
american sport
i don't i don't let anybody forget it
there's there is you know i forced
brendan to put that on twitter i said
yeah i said people need to know man
people need to know
well while you were talking we took that
off of you could see brendan hunt who
plays coach beard you could see him in
the reflection of the monitor of him
shooting it and he posted it on twitter
we just showed that video i mean so
that's
you know that's impressive right phil
very impressive thank you man thank you
yeah it looked like a proud dad didn't
he yeah phil dunster plays jamie tart
here on the rich eisen show is it also
true that you auditioned for the role
using a spanish accent is that a true
story it is a true story yeah the the
casting call originally went out because
they were looking for somebody who was
maybe you know a latino player or maybe
italian player someone that would sort
of you know from countries that had a
lot of flair when they played football
um and i did a spanish accent for it and
they're like
you're good
maybe your spanish accent isn't great
maybe we'll try and find they didn't
want someone who sounded like me
so they wanted someone who's like you
know maybe from an area where
um
someone's got to hustle a lot in order
to to get to where they need to be in
and for me you know i i know a lot of my
my girlfriend's family are all from
manchester um i know a lot of pop
culture from manchester liam gallagher
there's a rapper over here called h
who's incredible and there's this sort
of attitude to the place that just
really lent itself to like a bit of
flair a bit of show off a bit of like
passion um so yeah we managed to veer
away from the spanish accent enough so
that i could get the part thankfully and
then uh one of the beauties of this show
one of the many of them right is that it
it does mimic
um a lot of the or perfectly nail and
portray the the fandom that is
surrounding the sport of football in in
the uk and thus the chanting in the
cheers um you know the roy kent song the
chanter for roy kent being one and then
of course yours jamie tart to the tune
of and i apologize to all of my
listeners and viewers right now for
putting this song in their head for the
rest of the day
baby shark
um
is it true you came up with that idea
for that chant phil dunster is that true
yeah i'm i'm gonna i'm gonna stand
alongside you in solidarity and
apologize to all the to the listeners
who are now thinking of that song um
yeah well yes i
joe kelly one of the one of the creators
who came up to me and was like we're
looking for a song here does anything
spring to mind
um and uh you know it just felt like
the the the syllables worked in it and
it was really annoying
um and uh and so we we sort of together
we sort of came up with with that being
the the chant and um
and uh
yeah yeah it's you know it's it's um
it follows me around a bit now and
that's
i was about to say phil i'm i'm you know
uh i've been at this business and uh for
a while uh i was in a show uh
sportscenter on espn back in the day
and um the theme song for that is
and to this day i haven't been on since
2003 in the airport people say that to
me when i'm walking through an airport i
hear that i'm wondering how how often
you're hearing baby shark in your
direction
i came over to america a couple of weeks
ago for the emmys and it happened a lot
more there people people really think
maybe it's just that people are far more
forward in in uh enchanting your song at
you but uh than they are here but
certainly when people were like can i
get a video of you singing it i was like
i'm probably gonna leave that out i
imagine but you know
that might be a bit much you got to draw
a line somewhere phil you got to draw
you got to have boundaries no question i
agree with you maybe we could do a show
on the road maybe i can sing that and
then you can see the sports center i
couldn't like i love it by the way i'll
take that anything to be associated with
ted lasso and you for sure and so was
there uh uh a close second uh another
clubhouse leader till you suggested baby
shark um and then
well i was thinking because
it's like such a madly popular video
like a depressingly i think it's the
most viewed video of all time in all
human history baby shark is the most
viewed video yeah and so i was trying to
think of like what's a really easy pop
song i think maybe ed sheeran shape of
you i was thinking is there a way you
can get a bit of
that in there okay uh
you know a bit of elvis maybe but it's
just i think it you know i'm a pretty
lazy person and that was one of the
first ones i landed on so i was like no
that would work
and then just again just uh to to to
wrap all this up here um your character
and the roy kent character uh who's
obviously well i mean put this for
people who may not know he's more of a
of a grizzled old guard you're the young
guard and then obviously you're you're
you're
um competing for the affections for the
same woman this isn't uh you know as a
story is a as old as forever yeah uh how
is is it true you met brett goldstein
who plays roy kent and writes a lot of
this show as well uh before that you
have a history with him in some way
shape or form
yes i do yes i do yeah that's um i i did
a play when i was 18 years old
um and i just did it we did it for one
night only in in
london
in the big city and uh we've done it
because we tried to get this other play
and my the producer was like oh the
right is really nice um we couldn't do
that one he's given us a southern one
and so we did it did it for this one
night and then he was on the right here
and this guy was like beautiful man very
hairy big big big big big eyebrows
uh
you know turned up and he said that his
name was brett goldstein was like oh
that's cool i'll see you later and then
and then on the first day of filming he
turned up and i was like
oh my god he won't remember me he's like
i do i was there i remember it uh and um
you were fine you were fine in it yeah
you're good
um and but no he was immediately
um
incredibly welcoming and charming and
and
uh he's just like i can't believe i get
to do all my things with him because
he's uh
he's very funny and i can't believe they
still let us do things together because
we just spend so much time laughing um
i'm worried that it's a it's a drain on
the budget really
i suppose you know it just looks like
you're having fun it's just one of those
shows where you're just sitting there
and you're assuming it's not work for
those who are obviously working and
obviously plying their craft at such an
incredibly high level together as an
ensemble cast it just looks like you
guys have to be having a total blast
doing it yeah
we're cheating somewhere along the way
it feels pretty good and then i get to
speak about sports with you know people
such as yourself so okay it was like a
bit of a dream and then let me then then
then let me end with this then um
what's your real club do you have a real
club real football team real football
the greatest team of all time afc
wimbledon
okay you know to americans that will
think that you're you're actually
talking about tennis you you realize
that phil right you realize that to this
america sometimes they play they play
football a bit like it's a different
sport i mean you know it's not it's not
the most they don't really call it the
beautiful game when you're watching fc
win but all the time but you know we're
we're a small club but we've got a lot
of heart um
and uh and so yeah we're but maybe
manchester united are like my premier
league team that's probably people
people would know them a bit more please
tell me afc wimbledon plays on natural
grass right phil they have to correct
they do yeah yeah they do yeah that's
very good
some of them do play on astroturf which
blows my mind no it's just it does too
um well look um thank you for the time
phil this has been a blast i'd love to
have you back anytime certainly for a
season three and then obviously hoping
for seasons four five and six what have
you what have you the cast members been
told about this this whole concept of
maybe
well i think that we are holding fast in
terms of anything further than three um
we all love making the show i love going
into work with those people so i you
know i'd love to to continue but also
you know there's there's a certain story
after i think that they've got in mind
and i don't know how long that's you
know i i really don't know how long
that's going to take but i'm just happy
making this show and i'm happy to
continue if people are enjoying and
watching it it's beautiful it's
wonderful it's incredible and like i
said at the outset of this interview
tonight um we'll be excited my wife and
i to to watch it and then totally
depressed when it's over because we
gotta wait i'm serious like that's
that's how we feel about the roller
coaster of life man it's just you know
it's just uh it's uh yeah that's that's
how we got you terrific thanks for the
call phil dunster really appreciate it
congrats on what you're doing and i look
forward to more
thanks brother thank you very much you
bet phil dunster who plays jamie tart on
apple tv pluses ted lasso which you can
see tonight
season two finale starting to stream
right now right here on the rich eisen
show on the mercedes-benz vans phone
line
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here